what is the best thing about the best
thing about Rand Paul is that you seem
to master the language of empathy
empathy is something that publican
parties had a hard time dealing with
them by empathy i mean the ability to
see outside your own shoes into the
minds of someone who's experienced is
completely different than yours and and
Rand Paul seems to not only have some of
that language master but he actually
seems to be empathetic in a way that I
haven't seen Republican candidates be
empathetic in a long time in the Bill
Clinton way I feel your pain people like
to mock that it's really important
people really do need to understand that
presidential candidates understand what
they're going through and of course for
Rand Paul it it's part of the reason why
as he you know no notes all the time
that media says he's so interesting
because he's able to do this in ways
that that other other candidates aren't
so shouldn't libertarians which really
is what Rand Paul is shouldn't they be
the empathetic group I mean it seems to
me that if you were a true libertarian I
say this all the time on the show that
you wouldn't care about gay marriage and
you wouldn't care about medical
marijuana because you want people to be
responsible for their own bodies I
thought his answer on gay marriage a
couple weeks ago was pretty decent he
said I don't want to do anything with
the government if certain religious
institutions don't want to do it fine
but as long as it's equal under the law
a lot of gay people weren't happy with
that but I actually thought that was a
pretty okay answer especially for a guy
that's trying to get through a primary
where people are not okay with it it is
it is a perfect answer for that primary
I think absolutely and I think
particularly in criminal justice reform
in the way he talks about young black
men being deprived of their lives and
families being deprived of young black
men incarceration rates he just he
evinces an understanding of the issue
that I think could only come from
someone who's truly empathize and
empathy is a really really hard quality
and just general human interaction but
but also I think in politicians and and
it's it's very impressive yeah where do
you think like stuff like NSA and drones
where do you think that puts in with
with the party not necessarily the party
we're at the party elect NSA is is a the
party probably can support what he's
saying drones because if they associate
that with
on counterterrorism policies is gonna
have a problem with that yeah I
literally I just did a video any but I
literally have had a drone flying over
my house for like three weeks on and off
no joke and I'm like he's the only one
talking about it but I think the next
step forget what drones in you know
halfway across the world but it's groans
right here on American soil it's a
really good point in fact that we're not
we're not drones as personal now it's
not just the thing that kills terrorists
and Pakistan is yeah or or remarried in
our privacy broward Americans and in
collateral and innocent people but it's
also the thing that's just right above
us and zipping around and invading our
privacy and I think you know that that's
it that's a god issue it's a good issue
for him to run on in general election to